what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here with the return of Alyssa be crazy
which you can catch her on YouTube and
twitch add Alyssa be crazy where she
does gaming live streams game cavern
game tavern collective games with
friends that's what it is anyway she's
back III is going on this week I got my
gamer yes right throughout the week
because I am NOT a big gamer I just
started uncharted one last week six
hours a game play for me for every game
we guess it comes on this week from the
ether trailers we're trying to fund the
trip perfectly suit them a little boy of
hers named Anne that summer can said if
you're going to watch the trailer with
watch transference okay we don't know
what the hell is we have no idea but
we're like alright a bands recommending
it we'll watch it there was a sort of
synergy you would what we're looking to
do something interesting and then there
are those compass division and you're
looking to sort of bring you know what
sense you have of storytelling and put
that into the context if you are you can
for the first time as a player feel like
you are being a movie that's a really
good word for us we want you to take off
the gear and still see one hi
[Music]
what what your king is he'll be soft
we've stumbled across some fascinating
research that I'd begun in the late
nineties essentially neuro scientists
had figured out a way to upload brain
trauma emotional emotions memories to
the digital space yeah you know we've
gotta taken the next logical step
and with Aliza losing and recreated in
virtual reality a lot of stuffing kinds
of in Chandra we'd like an experience
[Music]
what you're experiencing is a recorded
consciousness not only watching a movie
sometime matter how real it may seem
again her to infancy be safe to say no
wait what I know is it is it like oh
your horror game I don't know if it did
but I want to play the shite out of it I
mean I've heard of this there's even a
movie that stars Johnny Depp that's
about that like uploading your
consciousness into a computer apparently
yeah it's terrifying is that what
they're saying they're actually doing a
video no no ask me again we got part of
it in scape yeah it's a game right let's
uh let's look good I think okay okay we
went it is very common for games I hate
them but I love to play them because it
is great us right out of me it's getting
a genuinely good scare cause like
whatever movie is different for me
because I kind of laugh at them I'm like
oh this is so unrealistic that it's
funny but playing over game is so
different because you are sit in that
space and it like played with your
psyche it's so scary but it produces
that genuine like terror that horror
movies should do Oh totally I'm
wondering if they're going to be doing
because there's not much information
release on this according to a random
article it's just [ __ ] but it's
seeming to be a blend of part game part
movie so I'm wondering if the game part
itself and where this is all going to
look like real life not video game
graphics but did they shoot this all on
film and so it's supposed to feel like
you're really part of something very
real the entire time I had the postive
er of a game because that would be
especially during buying if that's the
way they're doing it is very easy ah
yeah er which one did you play play the
one where you're going through the
carnival and you're shooting like clowns
and stuff oh yeah
CRA yeah one of the perks with that is
like if you choose to watch a movie on
it you're basically watching it in like
a an IMAX sized space yeah completely
like encompasses you which is awesome so
if they were to do that it would work
really well yeah would the cool thing is
Elijah Wood I know is a huge horror nut
the other one of his passionate really
yeah one of his matalas he's really in a
horror film I mean he's in the film in
general and he's in the video games in
general until I the horrors is
especially a big part of his heart so
the fact that he was involved in this I
imagine he's the kind of guy who's more
than just I'm putting my name to this
I'd imagine he's actually really
involved with it so yeah James Ian
pitches of psychological thriller
disturbing psychological horror part
movie part game that sounded terrifying
and transfer so it's like yeah you're
entering the consciousness of a
character yeah but if it's going to be
like part and part because we don't get
me wrong don't get me wrong I do like if
the right horror movies can be amazing
totally but they need to be done right
oh yeah and if they did this right how
are they going to seamlessly go from
gameplay to film and then drop out of it
that's what I'm wondering because would
it be kind of like in amnesia deal maybe
you play through something and then you
suddenly get a flashback of like
whatever my yeah yeah something like
that maybe it's interesting to see how
they're going to do this because it
could be jarring to go in and out of
yeah
I'd imagine that it's going to be weird
and trippy that that's what I imagine
like the horror they're going to kind of
go for is a little more on the absurd I
know the way the trailer was done like a
little shuddery things and also vintage
kind of look to it like the home video
type of style like it looks like they
recorded things on videotape when
they're showing but it's like
everything's going to be safe doesn't
look like up-to-date super modern-day
technology so I'm imagining that it'll
be one of those really jarring weird
trippy experiences kind of like you're
entering a nightmare because I hope that
the point they're pitching is your go
the consciousness of a mind and whenever
they do that in a movie everything feels
like a nightmarish dreamlike sequence
hmm so I don't imagine it's going to be
just like a straight-up horror film
reality-based I imagine going to be kind
of trippy yeah as you're going through
the weird dream state subconscious all
the red and thoughts collecting together
that's what I guess that's done so often
it's a little trophy by now you know a
little bit and it's I before E Argan
might be so good could it look so good
I'm not sure if you guys have more
information about it please leave your
comments below because according to
every article I skimmed through just
briefly was like yeah there's not much
information on it oh wait wait it
launches next year it's going to be for
PlayStation for Windows Xbox one and
will be compatible with the HTC vive
oculus rift and PlayStation VR that's
interesting
so going like across oh yeah yeah not
Nintendo maybe not for the child's Ned
[Music]
may be a great children's game right no
I do feel like this which could have the
art capabilities just a matter of time
I am totally he's holding right up to
your face alright guys well hey that was
a trailer reaction for chance then I'm
really excited I like to have my
consciousness into a computer all you
see are monkeys playing drums you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification Bell to be notified on
another forget about listening elissa be
crazy on the Alessa be crazy YouTube
channel and Twitter see livestream plays
game game tavern Jimmy yeah beep
sovereign is me Dan and a couple of
friends and we all get together and play
games and it's just generally a good
time so come hang out with us play some
games give you things links in the
description box go check her out
Alyssa thanks for being back let's watch
another lon